one of the insights that i had during my
episode if we can call it that and this
was being told to me is that if what i'm
experiencing isn't loving isn't somehow
life-affirming then see that as a sign
that it's deception
so move toward what's loving and ground
myself in other people and talk to them
and so on what do you make of that do
you see that as having an element of
truth
yeah i think yeah i will say is the
truth and love tied and if so how
very much connected because truth is the
essence of the heart
and expresses itself as love
that's my experience of it you see truth
is the essence of the hearts and it
expresses itself as love so the
expression of truth is love
yeah
so if somebody is not loving
meaning they're not completely open in
their heart
and the truth of who they are is not
coming
you had through
phrase about that the
mouth tastes what's material so i'm
butchering it but the mouth tastes
what's material and the heart tastes
what's spiritual
right
well that's some teachings like the
sufis think of a spiritual insight of
spiritual knowledge as taste
but it is the taste of the heart
that the heart is the organ of spiritual
taste
so the knowing
of spiritual matters they think of it as
a heart-knowing
and and they
call it taste
and taste you know
the arabic word
which means
like when you sample something you want
to taste it
you know this sometime means the
capacitive taste but sometimes taste
this
right
so when you have a spiritual experience
you're tasting something
so the heart tastes that
that way
so it get it to get get to know
the the truth the reality the spiritual
reality
so it's sometimes called taste sometimes
called touch too
and not touch